foreign
in the home of Grunge music Seattle
what's up Megan
hi I'm excited and nervous to talk to
you I'm excited and more nervous I
promise so we'll get through this
together what's up
my question is
to be 18 in about 10 days and he's not
motivated to
um get a job or a car or a license he's
not doing well in high school and he has
no interest in college or training
so how do I motivate him
probably go back in time 12 years
and start there start there
um
have you tried to love him throughout
his childhood by doing a lot of stuff
for him
yes I have I've learned that now lately
that I think that I over mothered
we're gonna go with the whoopsy do on
that one yes just for the sake of being
a single mom getting things done trying
to keep things moving
um and not realizing the consequences of
that on him yeah well hey high five to
you I'll give you a hug if we're if you
were we're in the same room and
um the fact that you've wrapped your
head around that is incredible good for
you
um also I don't want you to shoulder all
of this okay
um
when's the last time he had a stable
male presence in his life that actually
modeled what was coming next for him
so he really has has not okay
um his dad has been out of the picture
um pretty much from the beginning and I
was married when he was a young kid and
that only lasted a couple years it was
turned abusive and it was a bad divorce
and everything so that was
um that and then I have dated but he's
not had
like nobody from like a church or
anything like that that's kind of stuck
around okay
so if we want to
um get inside his head and pretend to
look out his eyes as he scans the world
um he has no
there is no path forward
he doesn't see a path forward let me put
it that way because he doesn't have
anyone who's modeled that for him
and I put that squirrely at the feet of
Dad
absolute dismo failure on Dad
okay
um
dad failed the Sun and so now we have an
18 year old who has relied heavily on
the love of his mom and probably taken
advantage of it let's be honest
um and I'm not gonna blame him he's a
kid and kids are gonna go as far as the
boundaries that they're given allow them
and um
and then when we're saying okay what's
next what are you gonna do
there's no picture in his head right
like I had pictures of my dad getting up
and putting a suit on when he was a
detective and then when he quit to
become a minister I had a picture of him
putting on like I just had a visual of
what that he doesn't have that
and so
many kids in his place have gone to one
of two places the internet
where they will it's full of images and
pictures of what this thing is supposed
to look like this thing called manhood
this thing called what comes next
or they just Retreat inside of
themselves and it sounds like that's
what your son's done
okay
here is the hardest I'm going to quote
my friend Henry cloud and Henry's become
a great friend
um he wrote the original book called
Boundaries which is one of the greatest
books ever
um
here's his quote okay
your son is
well I'll walk you through it and I'll
give you his quote your son right now
has absolutely no reason to think about
college none okay he has absolutely no
reason to get a job
he has no reason to graduate high school
zero
he he actually says that when I ask him
he'll he's like why yeah why like for
what because here's why
his remember we were talking about
looking out at the world through his
eyes
his bed is always going to be there
and food is always going to magically
show up in the in the in the
refrigerator
right and he's always going to magically
just use somebody else's bathroom yours
and all those things like the car is
just going to continually be in the
driveway for him to use and so Henry's
famous quote which I love is he's gonna
have to get some problems
okay and this is where you are really
gonna struggle because
you are going to feel your body is going
to feel his whining and pushing back and
crying and having to learn new things
and possibly ending up rooming in a
place that you don't like or hanging out
with people you don't like you are going
to feel that as a maternal failure and
it's not
okay it's the greatest thing you could
do for him create some problems see and
that's where I struggle with like
um where and when do I push uh you know
I don't know I think I mean given his
life his how far he's come thus far
I would give him six months
right and say Here's what happens at the
end of six months
you begin paying rent or you're out of
my house
yeah you are enrolled in college
okay or your rent doubles
you will also pay your portion of the
light bill and if you're going to sit
there and sit on the computer in the
video games all day you will pay 95 of
our of our internet service
okay right and so I think it's I want
you to treat this as though it's a very
professional interaction
okay which is here like just the same as
if you worked in an office setting
here's what what this costs the reality
here's the real cost here's what portion
of this you're going to pay
okay okay and this is you loving him
like you've never loved him before
um and you can let them know I will go
shop apartments with you
I'll even help you my Dad paid for my
first months
um to the deposit my first apartment
like I don't promise you helping them
out that way if you can afford it
um but we're gonna start a graduated
conversation here's how this has gone in
my house and my son's 12 and I told him
a month ago
after fall break we're starting a new
season in my house called a season of
excellence and he doesn't know this but
I'm taking him on a trip in October and
I can say this because this episode
won't air until we're back well he
doesn't listen to this anyway let's be
honest
um but I'm taking him on a trip and some
other guys from across the country are
going to meet us in a secret location
and we're gonna do a pretty cool thing
with him and with these other men
um and I'm going to begin treating him a
little bit different now we're having
different conversations
okay we're transitioning from him being
a little boy
that uh to where he's not a man but he
is entering into a new phase and I'm
calling it the season of excellence and
uh here's a good example this morning
um he got cereal
on his own and the the box was open and
when I got down and there was cereal
bits on the counter and I called him
down and I didn't yell I didn't scream I
didn't act like an idiot but I said part
of Excellence is leaving every
environment better than you found it
okay so before you leave son I want you
to take a look around and ask yourself
is this place better because I was here
or not
and I want him to do that in his
neighborhood in his community with his
wife one day with his spouse with his
kids with his home with his car I want
that to become a way he sees the world
right I don't want anyone calling this
show worse off after they talk to me
than before they called me right right
so I'm setting that stage now you're
gonna have to just do that in a very
accelerated fashion I got six years
before he turns 18. you've got six
months
yes right and so I want you to get super
intentional
what are the things
you wish the man you married
how he had treated you what he knew
about the world what he knew about hard
work what he knew about all those things
um I wanted to push you I want you to
pick up a book called The intentional
father by John Tyson
okay okay and I know your mom works just
it's going to be different but it is
what it is
um it's called the intentional father
it's phenomenal and it's a read through
a way to be intentional you're just
gonna have to compress this or maybe
you're gonna have to extend it most end
at 18 or 21 you might have to go a
little bit further but we're changing
this um we're transitioning this out
okay I also if you've got the ability to
find a man in your world not a romantic
partner but somebody who would step up
and begin to take him to breakfast or
lunch and
um ask him hard questions and challenge
him on things and teach him how to do
things like tie a tie and apply for
college and get a job and things like
that that would be fantastic
and yeah I can't
that would be incredible so good man my
dad did that for other people other men
did that for me
okay um throughout my life and it's been
really really good
okay he's got to have a picture in his
head of what this is what this can look
like
right and make no mistake
you are shaking up his
um comfort zone in a dramatic way
yeah he will fight this he will say I
hate you he will fill in the blank fill
in the blank fill in the blank
yeah no he turns it back to me he says
if do you hate me like when I'm like and
I'm like no that [ __ ] hey that is just a
move that is just a move you're gonna
tell him
I am raising a man that is going to
contribute
to society
I am raising a young man who is going to
be healthy and be well and be a positive
contributor to this neighborhood to his
family to himself to his country to ever
to everybody
so that starts here you will make your
bed before you leave or tonight you will
have no sheets that's the choice you
make you get to choose whether do you
want sheets or no sheets
you will clean up after yourself you
will make your own breakfast I will
never ever do your laundry again ever
congratulations
and if you don't have clean clothes
that's the choice you made
I will help you learn how to schedule
your time because you've never had to do
that before right so we're going to
break this stuff down and Mom you're
gonna have to get super intentional
probably in a way you've never been
get very very intentional what are the
skills I want him to walk out of my home
with
how much time do I got left what is that
going to look like
and maybe this all starts with you
taking them out on a date taking them
out somewhere nice
and talking to him about your childhood
maybe in a way you never have take him
out and talk to him about who you dated
about his dad
about your first husband
and walk him through how men have
treated you how it's gone how it hasn't
gone
and how man I I wish I'd done this one
differently with you and I didn't but
here we are
and everything's gonna change in this
world
as the great Henry Cloud says he's gonna
have to get some problems he doesn't
have they don't have to be problematic
but we're gonna start putting challenges
in challenges in front of him and we're
gonna stop lifting his weights for him
hoping he's going to get strong